Ich habe es kurz, alles klar.
Hallo, guten Abend. Ich bin Jahir Afjiu und ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch hören.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstand?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, bevor ich Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden frage,
möchte ich Ihre persönlichen Daten wissen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Jürgen Lausine.
Jürgen?
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname buchen?
Ja, der Vorname J-U-Umblaut-R-G-E-N.
Jürgen, männlicher Name.
Und Lausine-L-A-U-S-I-E-N.
Lausine, Frau Lausine.
Herr.
Herr Lausine.
Jürgen ist ein männlicher Vorname.
Ja, schön.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
79.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 13. Februar 1943.
13. Februar.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so 84 kg.
Ja, und wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwidert.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin jetzt natürlich im Ruhestand.
Ja, ja.
Ich war an der Universität, habe ich Mathematik unterrichtet.
Ja, Mathematik.
Sonnenuntergang.
Yes, this is Donna.
Genau.
Okay.
Herr.
Ich habe mich auf die Hand gekonnt.
Was ist sonst?
Was will ich werden?
Mein Hausarzt hat mich genau genommen geschickt.
Er hat gesagt, ich soll der Sache mal auf den Grund gehen.
Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ich meinen obersten Handknopf nicht mehr zu bekomme.
Und da ist mein Hals ganz geschwollen.
Und das ist auf beiden Seiten.
Das tut nicht weh.
Ich habe mich aber nicht verheiratet.
Ich habe mich nicht verheiratet.
Ich bin so ein bisschen schlapp.
Nachts muss ich schwitzen.
Dann mache ich immer auf.
Und muss mich zwischendurch wirklich einmal umziehen.
Weil ich so schwitze.
Und das mir aufgefallen ist,
ich habe innerhalb von relativ kurzer Zeit 5 kg abgenommen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ihr Haars geschwollen sind.
Ja, aber der Hals ist geschwollen.
Genau.
Und sie haben, wie ich sie verstanden,
sie haben in der Nacht schwitzen und abgeschlagen.
Ja, ich schwitze ganz extrem in der Nacht.
Ja, und in welchem Zeitraum haben sie 5 kg?
Ja, das sind bestimmt so sechs Wochen oder so.
Sechs Wochen.
Und ist ihr Haars oder haben Sie Schmerzen im Haars?
Nein, deswegen habe ich das gar nicht bemerkt.
Es tut nicht weh.
Ja, okay.
Und sie haben auch gesagt, Beidseitig.
Ja, das ist ja so.
Okay, und sie haben auch gesagt, Beidseitig.
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Gliederschmerzen?
Das kann ich eigentlich nicht sagen.
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Nein, okay.
Und ja, haben Sie irgendwo hin?
Oder irgendwo keine Schmerzen?
Ja, richtig.
Ich habe nirgendwo Schmerzen.
Nein, ich habe immer mal wieder Rhythmschmerzen, ja,
weil ich schon lange Bandscheibenprobleme habe.
Aber die habe ich ja schon ewig lange.
Ja, das ist nicht relevante diese Beschwerden.
Das ist früher.
Ihre Rücken Schmerzen sind schon früher.
Die habe ich schon ewig lange.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe auch gesagt, Sie sind fieberig.
Ja, also, stimmt.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen warmsaft ein paar Tagen.
Ich habe aber nicht gemessen.
Aber Sie haben recht.
Ich habe mich,
obwohl ich so nachts geschwitzt habe,
bin ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen, mich zu messen.
Aber ich fühle mich seit ein paar Tagen richtig fieberig.
Das stimmt, ja.
Ja, okay.
Schwitzen Sie nur in der Nacht, oder?
Überwiegend in der Nacht, ja.
Und haben Sie das Gefühl,
Ihr Herz schlagen, oder schlägt?
Schlägt?
Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
Ihr Herz schlägt.
Schlägt?
Ja, schlägt.
Da habe ich das Gefühl,
Nein, das ist wie immer.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Einatmen
oder Ausatmen?
Nein.
Nein, da habe ich kein Problem.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Einatmen
oder Ausatmen?
Ja, ich habe Probleme.
Und haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden?
Schluckbeschwerden habe ich auch nicht wirklich.
Nein.
Was haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, möchten Sie etwas,
diese Beschwerden,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ja, mal möchten Sie.
Ich habe Ihre Frage nicht verstanden.
Würden Sie etwas hinzufügen,
außer diese Beschwerden,
haben Sie...
Nein, das sind eigentlich die Sachen.
Ich fühle mich schlapp, ich schwitze nachts
und habe Gewicht verloren
und der Hals ist dick.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen
oder...
Also eigentlich habe ich keine Sehstörung.
Ich habe chronisch eine Binderhautentzündung
und muss deswegen immer Augen tropfen nehmen.
Aber auch das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Ja?
Und natürlich in dem Moment,
wo ich die Augen tropfen reinmache,
kann ich mich gut gucken.
Aber ansonsten, wenn die Binderhautentzündung im Griff ist,
dann kann ich gut gucken.
Ja, okay.
Ja, schön.
Und...
Ja,
oder müssten Sie sich erbrechen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also, ich habe zwar nicht viel Appetit,
aber übergeben musste ich mich nicht.
Ja.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Herr Lösen.
Also, ja, Schmerken tut es mir nicht besonders zurzeit.
Also, ich habe keinen guten Appetit zurzeit.
Deswegen habe ich auch erst gedacht,
dass ich deswegen vielleicht ein bisschen Gewicht verloren habe.
Ja, das ist...
in der Lesse hat Ihr Appetit verändert.
Ja, genau.
Ja, erst habe ich gedacht, dass Licht da dran,
weil es so heiß ist, dann hat man ja nicht so viel Appetit.
Und wenn man eigentlich nur etwas trinken...
aber irgendwie ist das alles ein bisschen viel auf einmal, ja.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen?
Beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, beim Durchschlafen natürlich.
Das habe ich ja gerade schon gesagt, weil ich schwitze
und weil ich auch nachts zwischendurch mal auf die Toilette muss.
Ja, okay.
Und muss man Sie sehr oft auf die Toilette?
Ja, so zwei, drei Mal in der Nacht muss ich schon raus, ja.
Wie?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stolkern?
Ja, ich neige so ein bisschen zur Verstopfung.
Dann nehme ich so Movi-Cool-Beute.
Aber nur, wenn das notwendig ist.
Ja, Ihre Verstopfung ist immer da, oder?
Das habe ich schon lange, ja.
Ihr seid schon lange, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Rückenchmerzen
und Ihr Wind...
Winderhaut.
Winderhaut entzündet.
Ja, außer dieser Erkrankungen haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen.
Ja, so ist es gut, dass ich ein bisschen erhöhte Blutverkwärte habe.
Aber das ist in meinem Alter ja eigentlich nicht ungewöhnlich.
Ja.
Und haben Sie schon einmal Ihre Routine Krebsversorgung untersucht gemacht?
Ja, normalerweise gehe ich da hin, ja.
Ja, besuchen Sie sich oft Ihr Aussehen.
Ja, eigentlich ziemlich regelmäßig, ja.
Ich bin zu meinem Urologen, und der guckt dann, ja.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Leuson?
Nein, vorwürdig, hatte ich noch nie.
Okay.
Haben Sie das bemerkt, Ihr Lampknoten...
Ja, das ist...
Ist Ihr Lampknoten fixiert, oder beweglich, oder?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht nachgefühlt.
Also ich merke, dass das alles dick ist hier im Hals.
Aber so genau kann ich das natürlich nicht beschreiben.
Okay.
Herr Leuson, nehmen Sie irgendetwas schon mal die Kommentare für diese Beschwerden?
Also jetzt gegen diese Schwellung, da wusste ich ja nicht, was ich nehmen soll.
Ich nehme halt die Sachen, die ich regelmäßig nehme.
Also diese Augen tropfen natürlich.
Ja, Augen tropfen.
Und dann habe ich so einen Medikament gegen diese hohen Blutverdwerte,
da nehme ich Simvastatin.
Dann nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Und wie viel Dosierung?
Ah, ich meine, da steht Simvastatin 40 drauf.
Okay.
Und Augen tropfen.
Die heißen oftalmin.
Oftalmin.
Und wie oft?
Die nehme ich dreimal am Tag in jedes Auge einen Tropfen.
Okay.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auch irgendwelche Medikamente oder Lebensmittel?
Medikamente wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich eine Erdbeerallergie, ja.
Erdbeer.
Das ist aber nur bei frischen Erdbeeren.
Also bei Marmelade oder Erdbeereis oder so ist das nicht.
Nur wenn ich frische Erdbeeren esse.
Und da kriege ich halt einen Hautausschlag, der juckt.
Okay.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona?
Ja, klar.
Ich bin ja in dem Alter, wo man auch schon vier Impfungen hat.
Ja, ich habe einen viermal geimpft.
Sehr schön.
Und waren Sie schon einmal im Ausland?
Ja, natürlich war ich in meinem Leben schon mal im Alter.
Aber in letzter Zeit war ich einmal zum Wandern in Österreich.
Aber sonst war ich nicht weg.
Also nicht gerade exotisch.
Ja, und brauchen Sie Herr Lausen?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Ich habe vor, lassen Sie mich rechnen, 18 Jahren habe ich aufgehört mit dem Raufen.
Und davor habe ich aber doch ordentlich geraucht.
Ja, da habe ich so 20 Zigaretten am Tag schon weg geraucht, ja.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Oh, das waren 30 Jahre, ich habe viel Geld ausgeben.
Hätte ich besser gespart, ja.
Ja.
Haben Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, ja.
Ja, ich trinke abends ein, zwei Gläserwein so im laufenden Abend.
Ja, jeden Tag.
Eigentlich so gut wie jeden Tag, ja.
Und das ist eine Routinefrage und ich muss das fragen.
Ja, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Selbst in meinen wildesten Jahren habe ich keine Drogen genommen.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, hören Sie, ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
Das könnte ein bisschen schwierig werden.
Ja.
Und gab es irgendwelche krönliche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie, in Ihre Eltern?
Ja, also, alle sind krank gewesen.
Ja, mein Vater, der hatte einen Kielkopfkrebs
und ist nicht so besonders alt geworden.
Den habe ich also schon deutlich überlebt.
Der ist mit 73 gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die ist auch nur 78 Jahre alt geworden,
die hat an Demenz gelitten.
Demenz.
Und haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ja, ist sie gesund?
Nein, die ist auch nicht gerade gesund.
Die hatte einen Schlaganfall, da war sie 73, also jetzt drei Jahre her.
Und die hat tatsächlich eine haltseitige Lehmung zurückbehalten.
Ist jetzt also ziemlich pflegebedürftig.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei erwachsene Kinder.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich bin ganz gut.
Und wo wohnen Sie normalerweise?
Wohnen Sie in Altenheim?
Nein, ich lebe alleine, ich lebe in der Wohnung.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren eine neue Partnerin und mit der lebe ich zusammen.
Ja, leben Sie mit Ihrer Partnerin?
Ja, genau.
Wir haben eine kleine Wohnung
und da kommen wir gut zurecht.
Ja, schon.
Okay.
Herr Lausen, ich denke, ihr habt alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt wissen, wie es weitergeht
und was dahinter stellen könnte und warum ist der Halt so dick?
Also, ja, da habe ich natürlich schon Fragen.
Aber vor allem jetzt erstmal, was machen Sie jetzt mit mir?
Was machen Sie für Untersuchungen?
Ja, okay.
Herr Lausen, das ist eine Dritte Schritte, um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Erste Linie ist eine richtige Anamnese durchführen.
Und zweite Schritt ist eine körpellige Untersuchung.
Ja, das ist eine richtige Anamnese.
Ja, ich würde gerne Ihren Hals untersuchen.
Und dritte Schritte ist eine diagnostische Parameter durchführen.
Ich würde gerne Ihre bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und einen Halsultraschall machen.
Und auch danach, ich würde gerne,
ich würde gerne Sintigraphie mit Ihren Hals,
Sintigraphie des Hals.
Was genau ist Sintigraphie?
Ja, Sintigraphie.
Das ist wie eine Röntgen, aber das ist eine, ja,
das kann eine, ihre Schildrüse, richtig, richtig,
wir überprüfen, wir überprüfen Ihre Schildrüse
ob es richtig funktioniert.
Ob sie richtig funktioniert, ja, okay.
Und, und, was ist das Besondere an der Sintigraphie?
Ja, das ist für, ja, Hypertro, Hypertro, oder ja, ja,
Schildrüse unter Funktion oder über Funktion.
Ja, aber was bedeutet denn Sintigraphie?
Was ist denn da, ist das Röntgen?
Ne, agentisch nicht Röntgen, ja, das ist anders.
Ja, was ist das technische Verfahren?
Das ist wie eine Radioisotope Verfahren.
Ja, genau, ja, okay.
Und mit dieser Verfahren, ja, wir müssen, ja,
wir müssen, wir müssen Ihren Haus oder Ihren Schildrüsen
überprüfen.
Okay, ja, alles klar.
Gut.
Und jetzt würde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen,
wie wir beide vorgehen.
Und zwischenzeit nehmen Sie bitte im Wartes.
Ja, okay, danke schön, ja, mach ich.
Bis gleich.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Gleich einige?
Herr Gündis, ja.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit Bock schmerzen,
besonders beim Gehen?
Oh, hm, ah, ich weiß, wo Sie hinwollen.
Ne, hat er aber eigentlich nicht.
Ne.
Bemerkens Sie eine Geldverbindung oder
eine Binderhaut oder Augen?
Augen?
Ja, bei den Augen, die sind ja eher rot als Gelb,
weil er immer Binderhaut in Zündung hat.
Aber sonst ist er nicht Geld, nein.
Haben Sie abgesehen von der Schwellung in die Hremhals,
irgendeine Schwellung in die Hremkörperbemerk?
Aufgefallen ist mir das nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Heiserkeit?
Nein, ich meine, aber hat der Kollege gefragt?
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Fragen schon einmal nicht sein.
Ich meine, er hat gefragt, ich meine, er hat gefragt, ich bin aber nicht Heiser.
Haben Sie sich schon oft mit einer Infektion Krankheiten infiziert?
Nicht übermäßig drauf.
Residivierende Hormax-Infektions, zum Beispiel.
Nein, also keine, keine auffallen vielen Infekte, nein.
Ihre Hauser einmal, mal Blut abgenommen?
Nein, der hat mich jetzt, der, als ich ihm die Symptome geschildert hat,
hat er gesagt, gehen Sie mal ins Krankenhaus, ja.
Welche Diagnose Ihre Hauser damalige Stadt oder gelten Sie?
Ich habe gar nichts gesagt.
Der hat gesagt, gehen Sie ins Krankenhaus.
Warum in Notfalls?
Mensch, Dr. Gündnis, ist es nicht überall nur Notfälle?
Ja, dieser Patient kommt natürlich nicht in die Notfallpraxis.
Dieser Patient kommt ins Krankenhaus, weil der komische Symptome hat.
Der kommt nicht abends um 8 Uhr, der kommt irgendwann
unter Tax und erzählt, dass er Hauser ihm geschickt hat.
Haben Sie depressive Situation, gibt es zum Beispiel?
Noch mal eine?
Nevestat, Unruhe.
Nervosität?
Eigentlich nicht mehr.
Depressive Situation zum Beispiel.
Auch nicht wirklich?
Okay, danke.
Das war es.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Ja, ja, können wir als Alsatzkischee anfangen?
Ja, gut.
Guten Abend Frau Oberarcin.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich möchte Ihnen über einen neuen Patient berichten, Larkisch.
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, Herr Jurgen Leusen
ist eine 79-jährige Patientin
und 1,78 m groß
und 84 kg.
Er sei verwidert und lebt mit ihrer Partnerin
in einer Wohnung.
Seiner?
Mit seiner Partnerin in einer Wohnung.
Er sei Rentnerin.
Rentner, Mann.
Ja, Rentner, früher habe er in einer Universität
Mathe unterrichtet.
Und die Patienten
stellte sich
wegen
oder ja,
stellte sich
geschwollene, geschwollene Hals, geschwollene dicke Hals
in unserer Notaufnahme gestellt.
Wo?
Ja, vor ihm.
Und er berichtet,
er gab an,
dass er nicht wäre.
Also eine schmerzlose Spellung?
Ja, ja.
Und sie klagte über Neuse
und Gewichtsabnahme von 5 kg
in sechs Wochen.
Die Fragen nach
Herzbeschwerden und Lungenbeschwerden
wurden verneint.
In der vegetative Anamnese
sei unabhängig, bis auf Fieber,
Nachschweiß,
in Appäten
und in Appäten
und häufig Wasser lassen in der Nacht.
Und wie sagen wir dazu?
Verstopfen.
Verstopfung.
Wie sagen wir denn zu dem nächtlichen,
ja, Nocturne.
Ja, Necturne.
Und wie sagen wir zur Verstopfung?
Verstopfung.
Obst?
Obstipation.
Anforderkrankungen ergab sich
Rückenchen,
oder Dorsalgie
und Chronitis
und Hyperlipideme.
Operation Gesichte
zahm by im
fernneint.
In Medikation
Neumea, Neumea,
Augentropfen,
oftalmin, Dreimal
in jede Auge
und 7-Mal years
einmal Abends
40 Milligramm
Erbürellergie
Sei bei ihm bekannt
und es
muss sich
Prioritapikke
mit dem
ja sein
Er ist im Moment nicht Rauch.
Aber früher wurde der Tabakabus mit 30 Fäketschern bejaht.
Er trinkte ein, zwei gelöse Wein täglich.
Und Rogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er war in der Familienanamnese bei der Mutter und der Schwester.
Er hatte drei Kinder.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben durften am ehesten auf Morbus Hochkin.
Und die als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen supertrösen.
Oder Larynx-Karsenum im Betracht.
Als Surveiterin abklärt, wurde er den Patienten stationell aufgenommen.
Ich würde aufnehmen.
Und so wie folgende labortechnische Untersuchung,
Blutbild- und Gerinnungsparameter überprüfen.
Ich würde überprüfen.
Und danach würde ich das Haus durchführen.
Noch mal zum Labor.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Was erwarten Sie in der Halssono zu sehen?
Ich würde gerne Lymphknoten und Schildrösen.
Was würde man bei der körperlichen Untersuchung machen?
Was würden Sie an Feindiagnostik machen?
Ich würde eine richtige Diagnose annehmen.
Wo nehmen Sie die Gewebekrube?
Wo überklären Sie den Patienten auf?
Ich würde die Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde gerne Chemotherapie veranlassen.
Ich würde eine richtige Diagnose annehmen.
Was spricht denn noch für die Erkrankung?
Das ist alles, was in Frage kommt, aufwendig.
Was von der Formulierung nicht glücklich war,
war es nicht so richtig, dass die Schicht designt verneint.
Oder der Patient wurde bisher noch nie operiert.
Was sagt man beim Hautausschlag der Allergie?
Wir haben Pro-Ritis gesagt.
Vielleicht kann es uns jemand von den Kollegen helfen.
Ich meine, Pro-Ritis ist die reine Rötung.
Ich kann mal gucken, ob ich das schnell nebenher googlen kann.
Ich denke, Exantin passt besser.
Sie haben sich wacker geschlagen.
Dr. Gündes ist uns verloren gegangen.
Ja, immer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie es geht.
Ich habe keine Schwellung.
Das würde man bei der körperlichen Untersuchung sehen.
Das passt.
Das ist schlapp.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Ich denke, dass man vorsichtig sein muss,
dass jemand keine Infektionskrankheiten hat.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Es ist eine sehr zuverlässige Information.
Es ist ein guter Hinweis.
Wir haben nicht immer nur Herr Gündes in allen Bundesländern Notfälle.
Ich meine, es gibt...
Wir haben in einigen Bundesländern
durchaus andere Fälle, die nicht unbedingt in die Notfallkategorie eingegangen sind.
Wenn jemand vom Hausarzt geschickt ist,
kann es in Bayern oder Baden-Württemberg geben.
Es gibt nur Notfälle oder Traumafälle.
Ich habe ein Kilotraumafälle in meinem Ort.
Es gibt nicht alle in Deutschland.
Wir haben eine Assistenzart.
Es gibt nur nicht alle Patienten.